foreign
is
[Silence]
subhanallah
is
[Silence]
we're continuing what we're speaking
about with regards to the reasons
why
a person's heart the causes
of a person's heart
becoming open
to the
quran and sunnah becoming open to
allah's
and the love of allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
what are these causes
well when we read through these 10
causes that ibn is mentions
he says this chapter is regarding the
causes for
the cause is for the heart being opened
the heart being opened
the heart being filled
with
love and
inspiration
from allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
what is
what when we look at this list we see
some of these things are things that
allah does
and some of these things are things that
the human being does
right
so
when we look at it in this way
we start to see that there is a
connection a deep connection
between
the actions of allah
and the actions of the servant
meaning that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
will give the servant
and the servant will then act upon what
he was given
and when the servant acts upon what he
was given allah will give him again
and that will cause another act and it
is a cycle
that a person gets into
the opposite is true as well
that a person may get into a cycle of
evil
right
that's why they say the scholars say
subhanahu
[Silence]
and
what
recompense
for good
is there other than good
right it's a rhetorical question
meaning the only recompense for good is
good
likewise allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
and the recompense for evil is an evil
equivalent to it
okay
so what does this mean
this means that a person may
lean into the fray lean into the cycle
of evil and become swept up by it
so they do an evil
and that will lead to a more evil thing
and when they do that evil thing it will
lead them to another evil thing
and that is the worst punishment of evil
the worst punishment of evil in this
life is that it leads to more evil it
never stops right there
and the greatest reward or one of the
greatest rewards of good in this life is
that it leads to more
good
it doesn't just stop with that one good
thing
it will always have an effect a positive
effect
that will
come back upon the person who does it
right
because when you do a good deed
this causes the pleasure of allah
and does the pleasure of allah have
effects of on us in this life
what's the answer
yes
are they effects
that are in real time meaning i do a
good deed and allah interacts with me
yes
and so yes it will affect me when i do a
good deed allah will respond
faith
allah responds to the servant as he does
good
just allah responds to the servant
when he does bad
right just allah responds to the
servant when he does bad
if a person commits a sin
if a person does something that is evil
you can expect a response from allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala but that response is
delayed
the response of allah to evil is delayed
why
who can tell me why
it gives you time to repent
what's the name of allah
a s
means the forbearing
the one who
gives respite the one who gives time
and so
when
allah when you do a good deed he
responds immediately maybe not in a way
that you imagine that he would respond
he is more
generous than his creation can ever be
and that is why one of his names is as
shakur
the thankful
a shakur lahuma anayan
al-manil
[Silence]
responds to evil in a different way that
he responds to good
meaning that when you do good he will
immediately respond
when you stand in salah and say
alhamdulillah
allah immediately responds and says
right
allah
immediately
remember me and i shall remember you
right
so immediately he will respond to that
good the angel on your right shoulder
will immediately write the good deed
but his response to evil is different
his response to evil is
meaning that he delays
negative response to evil
because he is forbearing and patient
with his servants
he gives you time to repent
time to check yourself and that time
might be
that time might be
a long time it may be years that allah
will tolerate
from somebody until the person changes
his ways
right
and so
there is a difference between the
response of allah to evil
and the response of allah to good
however
we have to now put iblis into into the
mix now
iblis
causes the sin
to become bigger and bigger and bigger
immediately
once he gets you to stumble he will push
you to make sure that you fall
and if you fall he'll sit on you to make
sure that you stay down
do you understand
that is not necessarily a response from
allah that is your enemy taking
advantage of your weakness
so
the scholars tell us that
the reward of a good deed is a good deed
that it will
that it will bring on more good deeds
but evil deeds they will also breed evil
a shaitaan will
experientiate and he will expedite that
evil he will make it come quicker
because he saw you stumble
so when he saw you stumble he will take
advantage that you're off balance
and this is what happened with the
brothers of yusuf allah
they were thinking evil thoughts about
yusuf they were jealous they started to
think how can we plot against him
so as shaytan told them
come on man i mean
murder happens people kill each other
but allah forgives you know
allah subhanahu ta'ala forgive you
you know it happens
it happens to the best of us
i mean look you guys are going through a
lot right now this is shape on you guys
are going through a lot
huh
all 11 of you and then yusuf and his
little brother benjamin oh they come
from another mother and they're the
special ones and they're closer to the
father than us and we're not
all of us together can't make up yusuf
that's not fair
right
you guys are going through a lot that's
a lot of stress for you
it's okay get rid of him and you'll be
fine after that you'll you for you'll
get the pleasure of your father and then
you will as well repent
and you will you'll be straight this is
the only time you're going to break the
rules
i'm going to break the rules only this
time
so a shaytan took something small and he
made it huge
the scholars tell us
that if you
look to the mercy of allah when you are
about to do an evil deed it will it will
turn it into a major sin
right
it will turn it into a mess
you are supposed to be focused on what
aspect of allah when you are about to
sin
what aspect the pleasure of allah the
forgiveness of allah or the anger of
allah
the anger of allah
when you're about to sin you remember
allah's anger
that will keep you from doing that but
if you go to sin and you remind yourself
of allah's mercy it will turn that sin
into an exponentially larger sin
so we now understand the concept of the
cycle of good and the cycle of evil
and we now understand that a shaitaan
will also allow you to do good things in
order to
get you to do bad things
what does that mean
a shaytan i want you to imagine with me
a game of chess
i'm not talking about if chess is halal
or haram okay it's just an example
i want you to imagine with me a game of
chess
or war for instance war
maybe is a better analogy
so nobody leaves saying the sheikh said
so the better analogy
in war
a skilled general
in war war is a collection of battles
correct
you have battles
and that that is the war
so a battle may last a day or two or
three but a war may last 10 years right
so
skilled generals may allow the enemy to
win a few battles in order to
defeat them in greater battles
a skilled general may allow
slight or seeming defeat in some battles
in order to win the war
and from this concept as shaytan
the some of the taberin
[Silence]
foreign
what does that mean
that a shaytan may allow you to do 99
good things
just to make you fall in one thing
what does that mean
we have to know a shaytan we have to
know how he plays this game
okay
it means
that let's say a person does a sin
right
say a person
you know
drinks does drugs whatever
so a shaytan
will
allow him and not not bother him when he
goes to pray
yeah let him have that
why
so that he will continue to do the evil
that he's doing
so he sees this as a greater evil so he
balances it
let let me win this one and you continue
to pray right and he'll leave you alone
this is why
ibn abbas
[Silence]
the jews claim
that when they stand for prayer
a shaitaan does not disturb their focus
he does not whisper to them and disturb
their focus in prayer
so ibn abbas responded and said
why would a shaitaan bother himself with
an abandoned house with an abandoned
building anyways
what does that mean
that means that they are non-muslim
they have disbelieved in muhammad he won
the war let them have that one
pray pray deeply with focus meditate
hard
right
that will only increase their kufur
with this shaitaan he knows that
because when they stand for prayer their
heart is full and their heart is this
and that but it's based on what
disbelief
it's based on disbelief
these are the games that a shaitaan
plays
so if you do something terrible if you
do something bad but then you see from
yourself doing other many good things
first of all don't give up hope in allah
and don't stop doing the good things
but second of all
beware
because the shaytan knows what he's
doing and he knows what you're doing too
if you find it easy to do evil
and then easy to do good
be very
careful because that's that's one of his
traps that he uses
am i making sense do we understand this
concept
the next thing that we're going to move
on to as
[Silence]
he says the fourth cause
of
a person's heart being
opened
and a person being inspired
by allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
is turning back to allah
and loving allah with the entirety of
your heart
what does that mean loving allah with
the entirety of your heart
didn't the prophet salallahu sallam love
his wives
didn't he love his children
didn't he love his companions
didn't he love his grandchildren
yes of course
so how is it that
ibn al-qaeda is saying the entirety of
your heart
when we see that there was a place in
his heart to love others as well
because he's speaking about a particular
type of love
a love that we hear in songs a lot
and this love is a love of worship what
is this love it's called unconditional
love
unconditional love
what is unconditional love
that no matter what allah does to me or
gives me i will love him
right
this is only for allah
and this is a type of love which is what
which is called
rebed
this is called
love which is a type of worship
that aspect of your heart
that aspect of your love is only for
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
if it is directed to anything or anyone
other than allah
it weakens your love for allah and you
are not loving allah with the entirety
of your heart
there's a difference between
there are actually
[Silence]
m
foreign
[Silence]
says
that you are to love allah with all of
your heart
what does that mean
all of your heart
when we look at the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
he loved his wives right
he loved his children
he even loved his uncle who died on
disbelief correct
died as a disbeliever
but the prophet loved him
why because abu talib was his uncle
first of all second of all because abu
talib helped him enormously
because abu talib
went through all of the trials and
hardships and protected him
isn't that correct
that you cannot guide those whom you
love this verse was sent down regarding
love so allah mentions that the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam loved abu
talib
but he loved him with what is called and
referred to by the scholars of islam as
natural love
natural love what is natural love
natural love is that you love someone
because of
either who they are or what they do
right
somebody is nice to you they they're
they're friendly they're this they're
that your neighbor mows your lawn or
whatever is always giving you gifts etc
etc is a nice guy you might come to love
this person but you don't love them with
a
with a religious love
you don't love them islamically you
don't love them religiously
you love them naturally
right
because they're not fighting against
islam they don't hate muslims as far as
you can see they they are good to you
they are nice to you they protect you
they defend you they do this they do
that so you love them
a person's mother may be non-muslim
would they not would they hate their
mother
in a natural way no this is my mother i
will always naturally love my mother
but on the day of resurrect when a
person dies
natural love dies with him
we understand that concept
natural love dies with the person
you naturally love someone
that natural love will come to an end
with your death
on the day of resurrection you will not
love that person
because on the day of resurrection what
is left is what
religious love love of worship
so i love
all muslims whether i've met them or not
for the sake of allah this is this is
this is islamic
religious love
i worship allah by loving allah
loving what allah loves and loving who
allah loves
right so i
i
am now loving in a
in a religious capacity
so when ibn is
one of the reasons for inspiration and
the heart to be open
is
to love allah with the entirety of your
heart
he's speaking about the entirety of your
heart the aspect of which is
a religious love
not directing that kind of religious
love to anyone else
directing it to a child
directing it to a parent
directing it to a friend
which happened in the time of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
there were people that wanted to become
muslim
but their friends
told them i will never speak to you
again if you become muslim
or their parents told them i will never
speak to you again if you become one so
their natural love
spilled over into their religious love
and that prevented them from becoming
muslim
and following the prophet salallahu
why
because they loved
in a religious capacity
someone they were to only love in a
natural capacity
his son died as what
one of his sons
died as a catholic correct
he was destroyed by the flood
and
was
hurt by this
correct
and he made dua to allah
[Silence]
you promised me my family
you promised that my family would be
safe
and my son is part of my family
and you are the most just in judgment
and so allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
[Silence]
he says to allah
you just you you my child was flooded
and drowned in the flood and you
promised that my my family would be safe
and allah said
he is not of your family
he's a son
how can he not be of his family he's not
of his
religious family correct
he's not of his family in a religious
capacity
he's of his family in a natural capacity
right but he's not of his family in a
religious capacity
and sometimes those two
bump heads
what happened in the battle of
buddha
right
that some
of the companions
fought their own cousins and uncles
and sometimes their own fathers
right in the battle of buddha
this is what happened
why did they do that because
their religious love superseded their
natural love
so there's natural love and there's
religious love
when ibn
says one of the reasons to be inspired
and your heart opened by allah
is that
is that you
love allah with the entirety of your
heart meaning the aspect of your heart
which is
the aspect of religious love it is only
for allah
sometimes that religious love
is infiltrated by that natural love
natural love becomes too much to the
point that it becomes religious
so some of the people of quraish when
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
called them to islam
their father said no
their mother said no their friends said
no
and so what did they do
they
followed what their parents said
they followed that this becomes a type
of worship now
it's as if they're worshiping their
parents
in this case
the natural love superseded the
religious love
so when we say loving allah with the
entirety of your heart
meaning that
you love allah with all of your heart in
a religious
way
and
that part of your heart is only reserved
for allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
it's reserved only for allah
if anything or anyone else is found in
that part of your heart
your heart becomes weak and your iman
becomes weak
and this is where we find in the quran
people are mentioned who have had
weak
faith
and they are referred to as
those who have
illness in their heart
what is that illness
something of this world
infiltrated that portion of the heart
which is only belongs to allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
so
we see this now
i will discuss this issue
you see people even muslims
but alhamdulillah in the muslim
community this is much less
okay
that they know that
for example
homosexuality is wrong
it's haram
right
it is an absolute abhorrent
abomination
correct but then
their child their son their daughter
comes out of the closet as they say
comes out
so they
start to change their views on that
topic
they start to say well you know it's not
so bad they'll go to their wedding
i love you no less you're my son no
matter what i support you all this stuff
this person has now what happened to him
this person his natural love has
over spilled into
a religious love
and that is exactly what will weaken the
heart and weaken a person's faith and
that will close your heart to the book
of allah and the book of the
son of the prophet
it's very dangerous
it's very dangerous to allow any part of
this dunya to infiltrate that part of
your heart which belongs only to allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
we understand that concept that is a
very important concept
our scholars used to tell us
[Silence]
they so they say
keep the dunya in your hand
don't allow the dunya to get into your
hearts
if you allow it to get into your heart
it will your heart will turn into a tool
that a shaytan will use to take you to
hell
but as long as you keep the dunya in
your hand
it will always be a tool for you
to
get to allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
natural love dies with the person who
who
who dies when you die your natural love
dies with you
and on the day of resurrection
[Silence]
so this is a very very important concept
that we discussed tonight we discussed
the difference between natural love and
religious love we discuss the
relationship between natural love and
religious love and we discuss the cycles
of good and evil and how allah interacts
with both good from his servant and evil
from him that is enough for tonight
he was
about